the house to go ahead my name is Pierre
de pot so um I didn't think I was gonna
make more miss out but he bros were like
you gotta do what a teacher you forgot
about the teacher the teacher grave is
the best one and yeah what is this
no what is this so that's great
which one should I touch uh I don't know
what's such this bacon this is ayah kiss
hair pin so we will go to Iook a story
now I'm so confused
oh [ __ ] what is going on that's me and I
again then we see Iook a story like a
it's really doesn't matter right now so
let's get somewhere safe nobody I can
say hi for a thing and I haven't even
looked at the bottom others are you can
pass the opportunity but I won't fine
what I chair ah this is mr. Padilla yeah
stationary no mistake its mr. Padilla
yes what do I care
she says and how comes the love letter
well let's go see what kind of juiciness
is in this [ __ ] sucker this is a
cursed letter if you don't send this to
five other people whatever alright time
to shaky out the lower drawer what we're
here well what what these arms what mrs.
satty stuff why why are these right yeah
like a pig
well don't touch that yeah good still
not rockin your body totally is
miraculous to stay fresh for over three
months
all the more to love what hmm
this guy's nuts and you you saw my
secret
oh [ __ ] Rose she's fought you can't
escape whoa that he's but he's [ __ ] up
he's [ __ ] up I tell you I got you I
got you
no running away now about earlier
don't tell anyone will you it's a secret
between us no no no I see that's
unfortunate
then a good job I akka you could've just
said yes I won't tell anyone
that's what they always do in movies I
don't listen you got a chance it's your
own fault Iook at mr. soda ah this is
what we played earlier and I guess we're
just the monsters my god what happened
ya know don't be fooled he was trying to
kill me so that's what she tried to say
uh I got you were attack
hold on she should say it I rent but
don't worry I'll be with her uh-huh no
way wait don't go wait a moment
oh okay so that's when he asked about
the tranquilizer right miss Medina don't
go help me how now then no one can get
in our way
no oh I can't throw like this think you
can to get away from me love this music
so awesome hey idiot girl you are the
one who taught me flawless who thought
me flawless you thought I was flawless
you thought of me as flawless whatever
but how did he get injured did he'd stab
himself or something it doesn't make
sense
mr. solo killed yokka
I'm so sorry I didn't notice I again
well we knew that already but that's
strange
why didn't miss Al's body rot that's
also the power of our curse even in
pieces she desperately tried to live
she's very keen on sticking around
alright so now finally we can do the
teacher story so that's great don't you
yes the moment we all been waiting for
where is what is this what is that what
is this guy doing
I can save here all right why not
a computer the screen is lit up inspect
it porn probably I was satisfied at
first I enjoyed being loved by all
computer you can't speak but suddenly it
was all holla it wasn't me who everyone
loved it was my mask is he talking about
his appearance
sorta the probably the Ayaka Erica she
doesn't know mister Sarah this is so
nice to delete the best a little
mysterious but I only makes my nipples
harder I mean it makes him better
luckily I am having him for homeroom I'm
so jealous
I mr. Santa you're just so beautiful
he's got a great face way better than
any of those boys
he's like a nice personality it's key
left Oh totally kinda reliable that's
teachers biggest charm it's not all
parents triple of just shallow [ __ ]
there you go all right all right
what dammit everyone always goes on
about my appearance idiotic girl stuff
this this is my face so you got plastic
surgery we're back here huh does he see
me now no he doesn't what's going on
here
I found a yearbook look inside is that
him
yeah hi Hideki Sora he's so ugly
who makes this face when they're gonna
take the high when they took the school
photo
SATA could this be mr. soda probably his
eye color is the same as his hair really
what what's going on here
what I do to win here sobre um this is
shudder that you just think up the class
go home you're filth
that's so main so soda got bullied to
and that's why he killed people who got
bullied when he got it what the [ __ ] huh
she dropped her hacker chief should I
give it to her she's gonna be like you
know uh uh huh what is it you dropped
your handkerchief huh no way yeah soda
touched it huh don't touch my things
with those filthy hands of you I'm sorry
I'll I'll give it back I don't want it
back now you're gross soda you jerk
you're making girls cry you're the worst
don't even bring your grubby mitts what
the [ __ ] is a guru be mixed to school
why they sell mint ahem that is so main
is everyone in school apparently a
[ __ ] idiot no one accepts me why
would anyone be so mean I don't get it
why would you be mean I don't get it
explain to me was that teach yourself
path wha the door up and hey spinning I
already the [ __ ] you are no one accepts
me what you can't run it
really really okay
what haha how do I do this
it won't open alright I'll go here seems
you couldn't you couldn't fit inside oh
[ __ ]
ma che I'm sorry go it in here
jump-scare in three two one
why do I do well oh I don't know ha ha
ha get Raj ah come on I wasn't running
either a [ __ ] cool or nod Ishita
but um ah nah why am I looking like this
what the hell
of course I chose the wrong one
Kyla come on really really I died
because I waited really me out what the
kitty why would you kill you kitty
why why does everyone reject me I hate
it ah meow a cat
it's Moon Bay May oh you look so fragile
I need to get you to a hospital
hang in there I'm gonna help you he's so
nice why would he kill people I'm sorry
but she's beyond saving
no [ __ ] veterinary and but Tyra better
than minute [ __ ] triple ax and so I'm
sorry if only I had found you sooner
maybe I could have teacher where are you
going teacher but if you're going yeah
so he brought it home I gotta say cuz I
don't trust this okay what do you want
no one ever accepts me that's what I
thought but she was different
you're really gonna eat that thing loser
so dumb
this dump is perfect place for soda ha
ha ha ha you said it I'd say something
the is so lame a scout yay
huh who's that girl I saw it before are
you okay
Takano she she was in mr. Selim yeah
sorry
do you mind if I stay with you huh it's
okay if you don't want me sorry no no
nothing like that so I can hi
oh yeah what do i do what do I say
tonics not saying anything either
why did Takano and talk to me ah Tucanos
hands are so pretty hey do you always
eat lunch here uh yeah I see it's nice
eh it's quiet and call me yeah I guess
it is
hey best conversation ever sorry what is
it I couldn't do anything when you were
being teased
duh don't it's dumb can I come here
again tomorrow
uh uh let's eat lunch together what you
if you eat with me you'll just get
booties I don't mind
I've decided I won't back down that's
what you do brows that's what you do
stand up I was feigning ignorance out of
fear I was turned from reality but I'm
going to stop from now on I'll protect
his honor
what am i bothering you none that is
you're not but but it's Charlie you
can't if you got teeth because of me I
am mean I feel guilty and having a girl
stand up for me I just be teased even
more I guess so
I really appreciate the thought well
sorry for bringing it up
no it's still I won't change that I
won't repeat it but come to me anytime
you're in trouble I'll help you with
anything
Takano thank you
that is shut up hey I want to know you
better soda that is the most precious
that is the cute she was the first the
first to accept me I was so so happy all
right well that's [ __ ] nice okay what
do you want we met there every day
afterwards we didn't talk to each other
we just spent the time together
conversation wasn't necessary my heart
was a teeth with the hair there we were
happy
but something went seriously wrong this
cat came back and killed everyone ah
that class look like a sheep
bravo Bravo best pick-up line ever it's
true oh she said it that's cute it's kid
yeah that God is smiling she's cute too
I love our hands and her voice and her
smile I fell for her my first love I
love you
Takano yes I do I really do I love
love-love-love Takano mm-hmm is he
humping her what's the matter
let go I gotta Noah I love you what I'm
so I love I love you talk huh
what ah Daka you creep
what what what I'm sorry
why I thought you accepted me why why
why oh look I'm really sorry I didn't
mean to get close to you for that kind
of thing I just felt bad for you soda
sorry it's nothing we should stop
meeting here okay huh why why would she
be nice and then end up being a [ __ ]
jerk no no why why why I want you accept
just friend
hold it hold on hold on you can't be
killing girls like that why why would
anyone except me
so stop why why somebody help
sorry what are you doing ah no one
accepts me no one well if you try not to
kill them
maybe they well I think I'm disgusting -
you think I'm disgusting - don't you
well I haven't showered so that's
probably it let's see how this ends oh
[ __ ] I do not like the sound of that
poor ChaCha's let's go oh [ __ ]
oh it's ads louder now wonderful
wonderful
he could be punching up a bottle of
water that could be the sound just sayin
or that or that
oh [ __ ]
why why does no one except me what did I
ever do teacher my face I thought if I
changed my face yes things change it was
a complete turnaround everyone welcomed
me I was accepted at last I was happy
but as soon I soon realized it wasn't me
or people welcome to it was my face no
one looked inside me always my
appearance this fabricated face if this
isn't me it's not me who was loved
just his back face I never been loved
for me that's not true teacher
everyone knows mrs. soda is a kind and
reliable teacher they they and I know
you're an I really nice part until mr.
Souder just a little awkward something
that's okay and I like it for who you
are well he's gonna fall in love with
you
don't do it Cordelia teacher you don't
have to be sad I everyone we all love
our can teacher that is adorable
ah at the world ball right thing all
right
oh and there's a kitty now sleeping
peacefully this kitty was happy being
cared for in his last moment so here
you're reincarnated as a kitty and that
yeah that that's it that's it if I go
saw an or fear it's just gonna be the
regular ending or whatever mister [ __ ]
take this yeah it's a mirror and all
that so that's the end I'm glad I play
that that was actually cool hope you
bros enjoyed it it was a little bonus I
guess you could call it I'm sorry this
game had this series on like five
endings
three hundreds of these alright thank
you for watching mouse-like traders
enjoyed and say awesome
we do it